the premise of the book is that people
aren't having good conversations and i
wanted to show them how to have good
conversations as you see from the clip i
mean i've gone out and interviewed
thousands of people and changed
thousands of minds not just the people
who i talk to but the people who
actually watch the videos and so the way
you do that is through asking questions
it's not about going and just
necessarily yelling at someone or
debating someone you can change
someone's mind by asking them questions
it's not necessarily about you changing
that person's mind it's about them
having their mind changed because they
can't answer the question that you gave
to them i want everyone to understand
what will just said there okay it's so
important for us to actually diagnose
and dissect what will just said he said
you can't change someone's mind yeah by
telling them what to do or what to do
it's asking them questions
and then
maybe even posing the questions that in
a little absurd manner and you put some
facts in your questions yes right and
then they have to answer it and like you
can see them i'm assuming struggle in
their mind it makes them think it makes
them think exactly fosh and then boom a
light bulb will go off like you can see
that so let's jump in let's see this
video with will
we have audio right
[Music]
what things exactly are you supporting
i hate guns free speech gets flipped to
be the ability to speak words of hate uh
words
that divide people rather than unite
people what is a word of hate um or a
sentence of hate that you've heard
[Music]
i
mean
there's a lot what's the significance of
1776
is that when columbus sailed the ocean
blue i think i'm a good man or a bad man
[Music]
no
no why not my husband's mexican
to sew i think mexican food is like
cultural appropriation
no
someone else's culture that we've kind
of taken
[Music]
do you think that the rich pay their
fair share
no
why do you say that
because there's so many homeless people
out on the street what is the european
union
european union um
it's a union
in europe and europe who fought in world
war one
all right
these people vote yeah exactly that's
unfortunate congratulations will
[Music]
you